[Music]  it's the 26th it's pretty much the end  of january so please welcome for what i  hope is the last time our new character  january  [Applause]  and ready jones fun he only shows up in  my number one scott world class  collection of trombones say hello to  january jones  now  i think you're great but as we've  pointed out before i i'm sorry you share  the same name with mad men's january  jones  you know i mean yeah did we ever hear  from her i mean does the real january  jones mind you using her name  oh she don't mind at all  she even asked me to be on the show  check it out  how you like my ideas donnie drapes  well it's your loss double d  january june  [Applause]  thank you january jones see you next  year  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  i'm glad that month is over